Drip.
If you see the telltale black mucus dripping
from the wall behind you, splattering down
from the ceiling, then it is already too late
for you.
The plaster will start to split, the wood
will warp and rot, metal will rust.
You should try to run, attempt to hide, but
know that he is coming for you.
The old man, limping along relentlessly, never
stopping to rest, to eat, to catch his breath.
He has no need for such human things anymore.
You can’t fight him, you can’t reason
with him, and you can’t kill what might
as well already be dead.
Just when you think you’ve found a safe
place to hide, you’ll hear a creaking from
the floor below you.
A blinding pain as something sharp slashes
through your Achilles tendon is the last thing
you will feel before the decrepit nightmare
vision drags you to his lair, never to return.
Even if you could escape now, the sickness
is already in you, skin already slackening
and muscles beginning to liquify.
He is rot, he is death, he is the disintegration
of all hope and light, and he has made you
his prey.
We’ve covered SCP-106, or The Old Man, before.
We’ve talked about his abilities, his hunting
patterns, an incident in which he escaped,
and a variety of theories regarding his origin.
It is unknown for sure where exactly the Old
Man came from.
There are three major theories as to his true
origin, which created one of the most fearsome
anomalies the SCP Foundation has ever come
across.
Perhaps he was a deeply disturbed World War
I soldier who gazed too long into something
better left untouched.
Perhaps he was never human at all, but instead
a divergent humanoid species that preyed on
early, prehistoric mankind.
Today, we’re focusing on the third possibility,
and arguably the most tragic of the three.
It begins with another man we’ve covered
on the channel before, named Dr. Robert Scranton,
and his wife, Dr. Anna Lang.
You probably know them for two things: The
Scranton Reality Anchor, and the accidental
discovery of SCP-3001, or the Red Reality.
In case you haven’t seen our video on the
subject, here’s a brief recap of the whole
unfortunate affair.
On January 2, 2000, at Site 120, Robert and
Anna were hard at work as the Head Researchers
developing an experimental device known as
the “Lang-Scranton Stabilizer”.
The LSS was intended to work as a Reality
Anchor, but it was in its early stages and
still unstable.
A seismic event rocked the research site,
damaging several LSS units, and creating a
wormhole that transported Dr. Scranton to
the pocket dimension hereafter referred to
as SCP-3001.
This little pocket of space, this impossible
world just adjacent to ours, has some unusual
properties.
It causes matter within it to deteriorate
as its Hume Level approaches that of the environment
- Humes being the measurement unit for reality
stability.
Robert Scranton was trapped there in the Red
Reality, alive, for a terrifyingly long time.
Five years, eleven months, and twenty-one
days before the logs he kept ended.
There, he struggled to hold on to himself.
He grasped desperately at shreds of his humanity,
his memories, even as the world around him
slowly ate them away.
Finally, only one thing remained: Anna.
His wife.
He could just barely remember her name, remember
that he wanted to get back to her.
There was a brief moment of hope, on December
23, 2005, when the LSS Control Panel reappeared
in a testing lab at Site-120.
Dr. Anna Lang arrived to monitor the situation.
A mass of bloody organic matter appeared alongside
it, and as Anna called out for her lost love,
something clattered to the floor and broke
her heart: her husband’s wedding ring, stained
with unidentified organic matter, smelling
of black blood and spoiled meat.
She collapsed under the weight of the possibility
that her husband was no longer lost in a physical
sense, but in another sense entirely.
That this mass of flesh, unrecognizable as
human, might be the man she once loved, tying
his favorite tie for him on date nights, dancing
drunkenly to Living on a Prayer, collapsing
on the couch together breathless with laughter
and the sheer joy of one another.
That he could be both here, at last, but gone
forever.
Dr. Anna Lang was taken to the medical bay
and treated for shock.
Years passed, after Anna’s last encounter
with her husband.
She carried the ring with her in her pocket
every day for the first few.
After five years, she threaded a chain through
it, wearing it around her neck under her clothes.
After ten more years, she stopped noticing
it was even on anymore.
It had become a part of her, engraved on her
heart with the memories of the man she had
loved, lost, and grieved.
With nothing to go home to at the end of the
day, no one to share her time off with, Anna
began to pour herself deeper into her work.
She would never remarry, she knew that.
Robert had been the only man for her.
Now, there was only her commitment to the
Foundation and the research she did there,
and the silent promise she made to herself
that she would never let anything like the
events of January 2, 2000, happen again.
But will they?
With no reason to go home, Anna’s nights
at the lab grew later and later.
Her colleagues often joked that she might
as well sleep there, since that was the only
thing she went home to do.
The sadness behind her eyes tended to cut
their jokes short soon after making them,
though.
Anna liked the late-night work.
The lab was still, almost serene.
She could disappear into the research, the
calculations, let them take over and quiet
the noise in her mind.
The lights were dimmed, no one was asking
her inane questions or bustling around while
she tried to focus.
There was nothing but her notes and textbooks,
the light of her lone desk lamp glowing softly
in the dark, and the work.
It was on one of these late nights, buried
in a mountain of paperwork, that Anna began
to hear a strange sound.
She didn’t notice it at first, absorbed
as she was in the sea of calculations.
But soon it began to permeate the room, breaking
through her focus.
A rustling sound, a crackling of sorts, quietly
murmuring into her ears.
Though she was vaguely aware of it, the way
you might be aware of the wind rustling through
the trees outside your bedroom window, she
didn’t truly hear it until she smelled something
faint but foul.
It was, no matter how muted, the unmistakable
scent of rot.
She stepped down from her lab stool, her joints
creaking with effort as she worked out the
stiffness in her muscles.
She adjusted her glasses, peering into the
shadows for the source of the sound, but saw
nothing of note.
She took a step forward into the dark, then
another, then another.
Behind her, the desk lamp flickered, then
cut out entirely.
She stopped, blinking in the sudden complete
darkness, and sudden silence.
The noise had stopped.
The only sound was her breathing, quickened
with fear.
She pulled the phone from her pocket and turned
on its flashlight, using its weak beam to
light her way.
She turned back to her desk, looking for the
issue that caused the light to cut out.
Perhaps a short in the wire, or a bulb that
needed changing.
Before she could take a look at the lamp,
however, something else caught her eye.
There was something slick and red on her stack
of papers, dripping onto the clean white surface
and staining it with gore.
A closer look revealed what it was, and a
shiver ran down her spine: a kidney, fresh
and human.
She couldn’t bring herself to touch it,
but somehow knew that if she did, it would
be warm.
Her heart pounded in her suddenly tightening
chest as the noise resumed behind her, wet,
slapping, louder than before.
Her feet moved of their own accord as she
walked toward the sound, holding the flashlight
in front of her in a shaking hand.
The black wall of the lab, illuminated by
the light, was smeared with something dark
and strange, slick like oil but with a rotten
smell.
A closer look revealed that the wall itself
was beginning to change, drooping limply like
wet cardboard.
She froze, watching helplessly as the wall
bubbled, crumbling to pieces.
Suddenly, a hand emerged from the wall, grey
skin slick with black fluid.
Its fingers, surprisingly strong, gripped
her arm.
She tore it away, scrambling back, and saw
that pieces of her lab coat had come off,
melting into the grey skin of the alien hand.
As the arm reached for her again, she stumbled
and dropped her phone onto the floor, casting
its light against the wall and the figure
worming its way out.
There it was, an old man, naked and grey with
slimy, decaying skin coming off in pieces.
Its throat was shredded, an open wound, and
it grinned at her with stiff shriveled lips
stretched over blackened teeth.
Its eyes were the worst part, even amidst
the rest of the walking corpse.
They were almost like a man’s, they were
correct in shape and placement, but they were
wrong.
They were empty, clouded over, and void of
any warmth or mercy.
As he stood there, the ground beneath him
began to dissipate, melting into an oily puddle
that enveloped her phone and snuffed out its
light.
There was only one thing left for Anna to
do, and so…she ran.
She turned and made a break for the lab doors,
lungs burning from the effort.
She cried out to the guard on night duty,
“Frank!” her voice was shrill and pleading.
He appeared from around the corner, gun already
drawn, eyes wide and alert at the panic he
must have heard in her voice.
As Frank tried to calm her down, and she tried
desperately to explain what she had seen,
the old man forced his way through the lab
doors, leaving a trail of corrosive black
slime in his wake.
Frank fired his gun, hitting the old man in
the chest twice.
He collapsed, sinking into the floor as his
excretion broke away the tiles beneath him.
As Anna and Frank debated what to do next,
a drip of black mucus landed on Frank’s
radio from above.
Another drop fell, landing directly in his
eye.
He screamed in agony, the mucus dissolving
his eyeball on contact.
Next, the empty grin appeared through the
ceiling, and the old man fell on top of Frank,
tearing out his throat with its bare hands.
Anna knew that she had to escape, but where
could she go?
She couldn’t think.
Couldn’t plan.
She just knew she had to run.
She ran until her feet suddenly stopped obeying.
She was stuck.
She was sinking into the ground, and then…she
was falling.
Down, down into a moldy, dusty hallway, dark
except for a nauseating greenish-grey glow.
She had been pulled into some new, nightmarish
world.
She ran through a nearby door, and found herself,
shockingly, in her old apartment.
How had she gotten here?
How did the old man know this place?
There was her bed, her desk, her closet.
She flung open the closet door, to find a
pile of rotten corpses that poured out and
slopped onto the floor.
She covered her mouth to choke back a scream,
turned and fled.
Then, she was back in the hall.
This time, she recognized it: it was a twisted,
warped version of Site-120.
In front of her, there he was: the old man
had found her again.
And now, she was in his territory.
He stared at her with those hollow eyes, and
for the first time, spoke.
“Red.”
He growled.
She stopped in her tracks, frozen to the spot.
What he said next turned her stomach and brought
tears to her eyes.
“Anna.”
He knew her name.
Again, he repeated, “Anna.”
He reached out to her with a hand that had
a tan line, where a wedding ring had once
been.
The same ring burning against her skin under
her shirt.
He cupped her cheek, and she felt the skin
sting and blister.
He kissed her, her teeth melting and fusing,
tongue turning to mush that dribbled down
her throat and choked her.
Her last thought, through the fear and the
despair, was the ache of love.
Her husband was not lost.
He was found.
And he had found her too.
Now, they would be together forever.
Now go check out “SCP-106 The Old Man”
and “SCP-106 - The Old Man Origin Theories”
for more on the terrifying story of this iconic
anomaly.